[Music]
here at one time they worked from sunrise to
sunset it
was an industry in our lord's power
[Music]
I'm the vab fishing and livestock
in the year 40 45 and in the 50s here there
would be the best working 670  people
then of course the Saharan bank had
to revolt with the fishing of the
treaty of Spain with Morocco of the
boats left the factory were
declining declining until they have
disappeared launching them
[Music]
but we have always been
producing
that is a lot for this never  it stops
[Music]
yes no
the saltworks system he
the saltworks
of the tradition maintenance change I don't go out to change a lot
hey image to load in the salt shaker the
rest you have to pick up your hand like the
60s or more ago
with  its washable rakes and the
wheelbarrow
[Music]
traditional system this is naturally
a good quality salt because it has
always been when people used to go
to the bank they would take fishing by boat they
wanted  n more the villagers to save the
fish because the fish can hold on, it is
observed
[Music]
now I like it we go about 10 to 15%
days that these 200 also
still have no future is that it is a
very strategic site because it attracts a lot of
attention  space
[Music] he
died at 99 years old and he fought his whole
life for the salt flats
[Music]
with the illusion that the salt flats
maintained them and that they will fight for them
because of course space has a
potential that is late x  years or what
will have to continue fighting the space
ahead for him
someone will have to continue
or
how